as omicron spreads
the borders are tightening yet again
from tuesday anyone arriving in the uk
will need to provide a negative pcr or
lateral flow test
taken no more than 48 hours before
departure
we're seeing increasing number of cases
linked to travel and again we've always
said we will act swiftly if we need to
if the changing data requires that and
that's why we've decided to bring in
this change of course it is something
that's going to particularly uh hit
people that were had travel plans and
that is hugely unfortunate but i think
the vast majority of people understand
exactly why it is important to take
action
receiving her booster jab today
scotland's first minister nicola
sturgeon has been calling for the
reintroduction of pre-departure tests
but those in the travel industry say
it's a step backwards
i'm afraid it's not good news for the
travel sector and it's certainly not
good news for airlines who were hoping
to benefit from an uplift really over
the christmas period we're going back
several months it's taking us back
effectively to may the worst hit sector
will be the inbound sector both tourism
leisure tourism and business travel for
those coming into the uk who simply
won't bother they won't want to take all
these tests so just drop it down by your
side for me nice and relaxed thank you
the announcement comes as the government
ramps up its rollout of covid boosters
around 2 000 jabs were given at this
site in exeter today hopefully you know
this vaccine there is some evidence so
far that it is still going to
still going to help so hopefully the big
push before january is going to
hopefully solve it
we've been waiting for our period until
we could book as soon as we could book
so we're very keen to come down i have
to say the organisation as with our
first two jabs has been fantastic
the prime minister says vaccination
centers will be popping up like
christmas trees in the coming days and
while more jabs are going into arms
there's also a fresh push to get
expectant mothers vaccinated
the phone calls are being told that um
excuse me sorry
that i may not survive a new video
released by the nhs hears from mothers
who suffered complications while giving
birth due to covid
and the hockridge is due in february and
contracted kovid just last month
having just had her booster she has a
clear message to other expectant moms
speak to my midwife and get independent
advice
not look online not read stories horror
stories on facebook but to get
independent advice from them
because they have all the data they put
the history of the science
the booster campaign comes as the nhs is
already facing winter pressure
while millions of extra jabs are the
main defense at home
the threat of omicron coming in from
abroad
means tougher travel rules
are back
damn whiteheads sky news